liz normally does 50 weddings a year
but in 2020 only five went ahead
the pandemic has left her with less than
10 percent of her annual income
i'm doing all i can to keep my business
here and keep it alive because
i've got couples that are waiting for me
to be able to do their weddings later
this year but it's expensive
paying out each month for things that i
can't use and i'm not i'm not
likely to use for a while critics say
there hasn't been enough support from
the government
it's an industry worth more than 14
billion pounds
and the pandemic has left many
businesses within it struggling
with more than 500 000 weddings in the
pipeline for this year
the continued uncertainty ahead is a big
concern for many
and a number of those working in the
sector are calling for weddings to be
recognized in the roadmap
out of lockdown the wedding industry
needs a clear plan
as to when we can open and to how many
guests
and we need support we have been unable
to trade in a commercially viable form
for nearly a year and the infrastructure
at the very heart of our sector
is due to collapse holly and chris
exchanged their vows in a ceremony last
october
but only 15 people were legally allowed
to attend
they hope to put on a bigger event this
summer but have been forced to postpone
it
until next year it's been really hard i
mean luckily we've had a good
good distraction with rosie
but it has been really difficult for
businesses and couples alike
hopes now lie on the current
restrictions being reviewed
aisha zahid sky news